here in southern nevada we're a little
over a week away from the primary
elections and this weekend locals all
across the valley are really taking
advantage of early voting madison
kimbrough is live at a voting site in
centennial hills near tropical parkway
and centennial center centennial center
boulevard rather with what you need to
know to cast your vote madison
now if you want to vote now is the time
take a look as we are here at the
centennial hills location as there is
only one week left before the big day on
june 14th this location off of
centennial center boulevard opened today
at 9 a.m and will be open until friday
june 10. the turnout today has been
steady with people not letting the heat
keep them from coming out and casting
their vote other long-term sites include
desert breeze park and the boulevard
mall north las vegas residents able to
submit their ballots for city mayor city
council wards one and three and
municipal court judge departments one
and two here's what some locals of the
area had to say about coming out today
why it was important to them to do so
a lot of people are kind of they don't
take they don't see the importance of it
and the significance of it and uh i mean
in reality it's a really simple process
you know each of our vote matters you
know so
it's important to come out and just do
you know do your part it's very simple
super streamlined just came in shook my
id had my ballot ready you know and i
just went to the
little machine there and i didn't you
know i cast my vote and probably took
5-10 minutes if that
if you are a henderson resident early
voting started may 31st at henderson
city hall access will be available
through thursday june 9 from 7 30 a.m to
5 30 p.m again election day is tuesday
june 14th this location here at
centennial hills is open until 6 pm for
a full review of candidates and voting
locations you can go on our website at
8newsnow.com reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now